[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
weird Monday everyone ah
well inflation is soaring our Southern
border is a mass Afghanistan is Terror
Central again and Budweiser just named
this as a new brand spokesman
but there's an even greater Menace
looming out there it's celebrities who
lost their status I'm referring to the
blue checks and I'm not talking about
someone choking on their stake in Prague
oh yeah I I debated internally whether
to leave that joke in or not it's
terrible
it's one of the worst jokes we've ever
heard
so I left it in
last week Twitter removed the user
verification symbols known as blue
checks from any account that doesn't
cough up eight bucks to subscribe to
Twitter blue the cash will go toward
replacing elon's rocket that exploded
it's a shame he only had two more
payments to go
including Kim Kardashian Beyonce
Beyonce Greg Gutfeld
and my personal favorite the Pope
yeah try try getting eight bucks out of
that guy
he always says he left his wallet in his
other Catholic
but then on Saturday Twitter re-verifies
many users with massive followings
including dead people like Michael
Jackson and Kobe Bryant
of course accounts remain active for the
brain dead
free or flee free blue checks for
several celebs who hate him including
LeBron and Stephen King it's a cute move
like when I loaned 50 bucks to Brian
stelter for some pants
what was he doing without pantsing and
Applebee's anyway but then came the
Meltdown from tons of celebs who want
you to know that they didn't paid the
eight bucks to get Twitter blue King
tweets my Twitter account says I've
subscribed to Twitter blue but I haven't
man he was as scared as any dentist who
sees his teeth
foreign
Alyssa Milano tweeted just wondering if
you all see a blue check mark too or am
I seeing things well let's say you're
definitely not seeing things including
job offers
then there's the walking stool sample
Patton Oswalt
remember him
most people don't he tweets woo did they
change your name then change it back
trick and the blue check went away good
to know
all right buddy popular journalists if
that's a real thing we're whining to
Maggie Haberman of the New York Times
isn't happy who says she didn't
subscribe and when Paul Krugman
complained saying he's definitely not
paying for it Elon Musk replied with
this
you know some celebrities went the other
way Charlie Sheen actually asked musk
for his blue check back and he got it
and then he smoked it
I bet Gene can't remember ever being
this happy but the media is tied up in
knots axios describes the blue check as
a Badge Of Dishonor slate calls it a
Scarlet Letter proving that the folks at
slate are so stupid they don't know
Scarlet and blue are different colors
and when did everybody get so weird and
that's coming for me I mean I'm weird
good luck getting an answer from Twitter
they don't have a PR department anymore
and all press inquiries get the same
automatic reply a poop emoji
that's why I like Elon which is really
how most journalists should be treated
because they're needy d-bags fully
but back in the old days by which I mean
10 years ago a blue check simply meant
that you were who you claimed to be all
you had to do was show them ID just like
when I claim my AARP discount at
Cinnabon
then pre musk's Twitter started taking
away people's blue checks for saying
things that angered Libs conform or we
won't let you be you and that never made
any sense that changed the blue check
from a very simple verification to some
sort of status symbol once again
anything Libs touch turns to crap now
blue check man you were better than
everybody else and then Elon bought the
place started selling the blue checks
for eight bucks to anyone who wanted to
pay and what did that do well in the
insecure heads of celebrities and media
hacks it sap their status they felt
miserable their Velvet Rope didn't keep
the little people out so blue check no
longer projected their superiority
celebs had a little block of pixels that
they saw as a status symbol and now they
see it as the opposite because it's just
not fair to them when people are treated
equally
yes it's silly for a billionaire to make
it look like famous people are paying
for his app also it's silly for famous
people to panic that it looks like
they're paying for a Billionaire's app
can everybody just take a break and
pretend they're not crazy for five
minutes life has started to feel like a
pre-board for a Spirit Airlines flight
being a liberal must be so exhausting
from one moment to the next you don't
know who's your friend and who's your
foe it could change back and forth at
any moment heck could happen to me today
you know we could totally tweet as Greg
and no one would know the difference
he'll never pay that eight bucks how
about this one for her the only reason I
make fun of Kilmeade so much is because
I secretly want to be him hashtag
handsomtownpost nice oh I got one uh the
only thing I love more than the Red Hot
Chili Peppers is the view hashtag best
show on TV post noise how about this one
Geraldo had some good points last night
post get back to work and no pee breaks
but sir employee 6147 forgot his page
are then hold it
I love you father it's okay you can use
mine
excellent acting by the way
and I'm not his father but in case
you're wondering I might actually pay
for the Twitter blue check myself only
because it matches my beautiful eyes and
I don't want people pretending to be me
well unless they're funnier
[Applause]
tonight's guests
at 3 P.M she's the perfect compliment to
your day drinking oh so this story
Martha McCallum
cheers that's what Hollywood said when
they told him to leave TV writer and
producer Rob long
he's like The Fawns because he wears a
leather jacket and lives over your
parents garage editor at large it reason
nicholaspy
[Applause]
and finally she's like the Unabomber
writing prolifically without bathing
Fox's contributor cat tip
thank you
Rob there's this phony debate going on
or should I call you Professor Rob well
I'm talking about a phony debate you
just call me Mr Rob yes the um people
talk about oh this is about promotions
about money this is about an emotional
need I people have to admit that they're
on Twitter because it serves as an
emotional attachment everybody goes no I
I'll even say this I do this to promote
my book or I do this because you know
blah blah blah people do actually but
they can't admit it to others
right I mean I think it's important to
remember that a lot of people don't do
it right it's one of the reasons why
it's kind of a difficult business a lot
of people aren't on it some people have
this thing they they exist in real life
they have like real friends so this is
kind of a media story about media people
being mad about a media story about
media people and I think it's kind of
like I want everyone to take a deep
breath because I I had a blue check and
I'd pay for it but I I had one and I
didn't know what it did for me except I
guess it kept people's from tweeting as
me as if anybody would right you want to
do that I could no longer masquerade as
you and hit on male gymnasts well but
you but that did not stop you from doing
that that is true uh so I uh so I was
doing undercover work to me it feels
like this like this sort of you an
ordinary person you have to explain so
much about this story first of all I
explain what Twitter is and then what
people do on it and then why there's a
blue check and then why there isn't a
blue check and then why you pay for this
is exactly the problem with sort of
media in general is that it's a it's a
kind of their they're so far up their
own you can say it can you yeah they're
so far up their own ass wow I really
apologize
this is a classy show I hate to bring it
down yeah it's always a shock when Burl
Ives swears yeah
foreign
[Music]
that was a really good one thank you you
know
[Applause]
I wish that you spent ten percent of
that creativity on your monologue
[Music]
yeah he's right
you're right though it's like media on
media on media and then we do a
monologue on it Martha does any of this
matter do we matter
you know I mean it really it it just
sort of brings home the whole question
of this likes and checks and all of you
know how many followers you have and how
ridiculous the whole thing has become
that people are freaking out that they
don't have a blue check and then dead
people have a blue check and they can't
tweet at all
um so it it's kind of I think it is kind
of bringing home how separate
the group of people are who actually go
on I thought that um Bette Midler was my
favorite complainer though overall she
was like she said you tweaked the
algorithm and tanked my metrics and I
thought if anybody read this you know 10
years ago they'd be like what did what
is she talking about you tweaked my
algorithm and tanked my metrics and then
at the bottom which I thought was kind
of funny even though I love the Elon
Musk space program she said sorry about
your rocket
at least he puts a rocket into space
exactly what if you put into space
besides Twinkies
see again yeah just a little bit more uh
effort away from me and my appearance I
don't know that seems to be the gold
mine I guess you're right
Nick it seems like if a lot of people
are getting their blue checks we should
start just tweeting as famous people
I've been trying I've been impersonating
myself for the past five minutes it
doesn't matter I liked having the blue
check you know before you have to pay
for it which I may do but because a
couple people I work with didn't have it
and I would always be like you know it
really doesn't matter that I have this
blue check that you don't have really
you can bring it up in almost any
contact yes and because they're
journalists they get mad yeah they're so
easy yeah you just bring it up even
without even any prompting remember that
time at the funeral when you brought it
up
oh it was you know I thought it was
appropriate yes it was it was people
were crying anyway
you know that's part of my philosophy
always give bad news to people who are
suffering that would be great yeah right
you'd give them because it's like it
can't get any worse well while you're
here you're fired
cat isn't this really about the human
like weakness uh the human desire for
status that we're always trying to look
for it and it undermines everything and
underpins everything I think yeah
especially because we're all gonna die
yeah good good point well that's what I
always think about most of the time yeah
this guy's not oh that's a lot better
looking as I get older okay I am too but
I'm still gonna die you have your blue
check buddy do I yeah no I don't yes you
do everybody with more than a million
followers has the blue child oh really I
have 2.7 million yeah
does that mean I should get two points I
also knew you were gonna bring that up
so you're like some people care about
status so much yeah but I have 2.7
million followers and I I don't have a
million followers so I don't have a blue
check but I don't want to pay for it
because although I am concerned about
maybe the limited reach of my fiery hot
takes I don't want people to know that
right I want to make a correction that I
actually have 2.4 not 2.7 million
um you know it's funny because I was
going to talk about how weak it is that
people are so attached to things that
give them status but in your face yeah I
was like what is he talking about in
your face yeah no I thought you made
that clear yes look at that
see that right I can see it yeah it's a
little blue check huh yeah it's like
it's like a it's like the opposite of a
malignant mole
it's a beauty mark oh you should work in
marketing I should work it's really
pathetic I mean it's so pathetic I know
about what we're talking about it's like
I mean the only people I was ever happy
that I impressed with my blue check were
my kids yeah oh she her she was a check
Martha you look like a you look like a
doctor from the future really maybe I am
a doctor for the future here to
diagnosis
[Laughter]
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else